hello I'm Grandmaster Dennis Porsche and
this is a grandmasters choice today
actually we're going to look at games of
akeeba Rubinstein I see so many fans of
akeeba now this game might not be the
most famous one where he's playing
against burn Olmos
I'm not quite sure myself who he is but
Rubinstein is going to make a short work
of him now right now we are actually
facing some trouble there's a classical
double attack and black can't really do
much about it goes Bishop d6 and I take
c4 and the topic of the day is
Rubinstein Rubinstein is famous for his
endgame technique and this won't be no
exception well if you look at this
position what will come to mind first
well obviously why--just equalised was
down upon but now black has a choice
whether to try and find a retreating
move or take actions so Rubinstein
decides to take action because he felt
like as we started from the beginning
position that he got really active one
upon through tactical sequence and felt
that it's just the right time
to do something so he took on c4 take 92
take six and that's a big shift from the
position that we just had before now we
barely have any pieces left but on the
other hand this would be an advantage to
the defender or the attacker
so it is definitely an advantage that we
already have a rook on the second on the
other hand we did exchange a lot of
pieces so if I go back just a little bit
we still have like three like me pieces
but after take 692 you know almost down
to one pair one Bishop each so if
they're Bishop a3 the advantage is not
that big and also as we know if you get
into the rook endgame it can easily end
up drawn so Rubenstein decides to take
on a three takes rook e8 now this is
important to notice of always bring your
pieces and guys on the Open File rook e8
King f1 just safeguarding that e1 square
doctor not square right there and now
black plays a very strong move and so
anyone who's not familiar with
Rubenstein
he's very accurate when it comes to end
games and mostly he's trying to restrict
his opponents options if you're looking
at this one and you look trying to solve
this puzzle here you should be trying to
basically suffocate White's play if he
would be white which open father would
love to have the B file so white really
desperately wants to get contour play on
the B file Rubenstein is just going to
stop that idea and play Ruby too
so as you can see this is 1912 so
there's a lot of theories to be
discussed they don't know a whole lot
they haven't even refuted the tirage
defense yet or they haven't found the
right concept how to play against it and
what's actually funny that Rubinstein
who played the Taurus variation himself
he was the one to come up with the most
effective way of playing against that
but anyways that's enough talk about
openings the way he handles end games is
going to be practiced by future
challenges such as Boris Gelfand he's
actually a big fan of Rubinstein so
rugby - basically taking away the B file
you can't really take it away from my
rook also note that this rook on a3 is
stranded it can't really do anything
there so if you're on the defensive side
if you're on the side of Bernanos what
would be an interesting and the
well-tried strategy to try to defend a
slightly worse position in brooklyn
games
also note that y doesn't have that much
space exactly you do want to simplify so
he plays rook e1 and again would we want
to move our rook away not really we
don't want to give free counter play for
white that wouldn't be nice
so Rubenstein again come comes up with a
nice little prophylactic move
place King f8 and this is vintage
Rubinstein his a tries to restrict his
opponents moves and possibilities and B
he's trying to get one inch forward at a
time
it doesn't always win but it maximizes
his chances so in some ways this does
remind me of cousins play in end games
he's trying to grab as many chances as
they could get
I mean both of them try to so a5 trying
to gain some extra space rook e1 and
note that if he would take on e1 we
would give the extra option for white to
come up with a different plan so let's
say not rookie 6 so takes takes King f8
I could decide to play c4 instead even
though probably will be for hope it's a
problem but you're giving extra options
that you shouldn't be giving so
therefore Rubinstein goes King f8 you
know I I want to see what you're going
to do next and basis place bases play
upon that say five rook takes c1 a6
again the whole point here is black is
trying to box in that rook now that rook
cannot really move and if you would try
to move it back then the a pawn will
become a weakness c4 King g7 so if we
look at this position what are the big
major differences between White's
position and blacks position
yeah this king is way more active and
also is much closer to the action than
the white counterpart which is stranded
on the first rank which is never ideal
in end games what else what else can we
notice
if you talk about rook's what is the big
difference
yep so this b2 rook is plays really well
it defends the only weakness also note
how good a six was there's only one
weakness left for black on the Queen
side while this white rook on a3 is
doomed to defend these pawns
so rookies we check King d7 rook f3 so
do we want to create some weaknesses on
the Kings side nope we don't so he goes
back can get fate and sometimes you
notice this that grandmasters and super
grandmasters toy with their opponents
now we could say it okay so what did
black achieve doing this back and forth
shuffling well mostly is just to mess
with your opponent's reigns and saying
okay I didn't necessarily make progress
here but what are you going to do about
it
now it would be extremely sad to go back
to a3 so it doesn't do that he goes
rookie to trying to go on exchange of
the rooks
will they agree to that gracious offer
nope No Deal check row k1 and suddenly
the white king activated but the a5 pawn
became a weakness
yeah the king is in the way rookie 5 f6
and suddenly this rook will find itself
stuck somewhere on the fifth rank which
is not ideal it would rather roam free
on the B file but that's a dream sir
rook c5 that's a sad rook King g7 d5 is
not advised because King b6 and we say
bye-bye does that rook hello
so why play is h4 now honestly this
looks like a big advantage on the
surface in fact black is just a little
bit better because you can't really
exploit the fact that this rook is
stranded there once you get the chance
to exploit it dan Rubinstein will get
real winning chances but he's not there
yet
rokay 3 again what's exciting about
Rubenstein's and games and rook and
games is his unhurried style he's not
necessarily trying to achieve like an
immediate goal winning upon he's trying
to limit the options for white so this
King cannot really come up which would
it would love to do and now again Byrne
has to come up with an idea himself and
sometimes those turn out to be mistakes
rook age 5 8 6 so note that Rubenstein
put all these pawns up here so there
could be Val defended g3 and let me see
this
it might not be the move that Rubinstein
will play but what will be the future
plan of Rubinstein so first off he tries
to restrict the play of his opponent but
eventually he goes all away to the other
side to come up with the winning attempt
so what would be the big game plan for
Rubinstein here
so one idea is to play against the rock
right the rock just looks awful on h5
but unfortunately even though we can try
and trap it here hope that wants to be
g6 actually oh so wants to go can you
have seven and g6 but the Rope can all
the time go back to c5 so we can't
really win it anymore in fact that is
one of the drawbacks of this a6 move
that now we will never have v6 ideas
with the trick of trapping that rook on
c5 so anyways he played h6 King g6 again
a typical Rubinstein moves not showing
the clear intentions just waiting asking
okay what are you going to do about it
rook c5 and now g6 as you can see he's
slowly taking the air away from this
rook in fact that rook is stuck right
now
kingi to h5 so now plans are getting
shaped so first off maybe in the future
g5 could be an idea just to create a
passport but probably that will be
dangerous and if that's dangerous where
else could we try to create a passer
well on the queenside we can go ahead
walk over and break it open the d6 and
then we can hope that the a pond could
start running so king d2 king D 6 king
he to king c7 FG and in fact we should
give credit where credit is due
Byrne was waiting himself he said okay
you're waiting I'm not going to show my
plans
you sure what you're trying to do then
on this side and that's a good defensive
strategy actually King c7 f3 d6 take six
and look this rook is still stuck on c5
in fact there's no places it could go to
we took all those squares away so berm
plays G 4-h takes F takes rope g3 g5 f
takes if f5 sadly there would be some h5
moves and also the rook could get into
the play and we don't want that F takes
rook takes g5 and in fact this was a big
mistake
but you know even in tennis or in other
sports you would call this unforced
errors but in fact you've seen that
Rubenstein's been grilling white for 30
moves by now
so rook takes g5 burn was just so happy
to exchange off that terrible rook that
he took the first chance that he got but
this time this one is losing in fact its
ethics geez g5 would have given some
drawing chances because it's still a
rockin game with the hopes of drawing
probably takes a5 and eventually that
rookie 5 and the rook getting behind the
pawn would give ample chances for a draw
but he played rook takes g5 but this was
a big mistake
that's why to move and when hmm black to
move and when that is
and I would assume that bird calculated
this variation but missed a concept that
just didn't cross his mind
so obviously it took H takes
King c7 and if I walk this way
yeah but then I'll start pushing my deep
on that's the problem
so King c7 is a little slow here many
other ideas King a5 yes and that is the
big move probably white anticipated a5
but then the king could potentially get
in there in time but totally miss the
concept move of King a5 and getting the
King in first king d3 king before the 5
and suddenly we go back and defend and
that's all she wrote basically as I'm
going to stop you from getting in and I
just start pushing my a pawn and here
takes
maybe four
just win the ending just push up the
pond and it's one so the big critical
moment was the king gave five king
before and probably that's what burn
missed all right so game number two and
this one is between Marshall and
Rubinstein Marshall obviously known for
the Marshall variation and his very
entertaining play here he's defending
against Rubinstein but as far as I count
the pieces it looks fairly equal to me
but again Rubinstein is relentless when
it comes to putting pressure if you look
at this position can we spot the best
piece for white which one is the best
piece here
the bishop is a monster on c4 that'd be
the first thing for Rubenstein to get
rid of now you can't really take on a
six because we should takes b3 and
that's all you lose the game
so Bishop takes d5 rook takes d5 King f2
and at the moment that looks scary for
black because the king is coming and
inching closer to take that pawn and
this is the moment when Rubenstein
realizes that he needs to change plans
so if you just wait around we're just
going to lose the pawn and we'll be the
ones suffering so we need to come up
with an active plan here
so we can't really walk up with the king
because might we'll be just in time to
take the pawn and defend it from c-2 so
black needs to get active in place rook
d3 king he to rugby three rook d2 and
now we need to decide where to put our
rocks our oak
and this is crucial if black miss places
miss laces this part of the game then it
will be just a complete draw the the
upcoming few moves Rubinstein makes it
sure and certain that he'll be the only
one present
if you go over k3 if I go Rudy for
hmm if I play f4
ah didn't you go over okay three all you
said not eighty-five you said
eighty-five oh okay sorry my bad I I
heard a five there so root K three rugby
400 K 3 we'll d4 d5 I move my rook away
to be four and if you go a five I'll
double attack your pawns and then I'm
probably gonna check you on the six and
seven
so think about restricting the mobility
of your opponent's pieces the first move
is just going to achieve that so we all
know that in the brook and game you need
to have an active rook if you get a
passive one that's not a good sign
so you played rugby for with the idea of
eventually forcing this rook to go to a
to where it's not a happy camper Roque -
and eventually viola try to play a five
plot we play a five ourselves and that
rookie is just going to stare at that
pawn for a while now and it's stuck
there whenever you move I'll take the a4
pawn so it stuck defending there is this
winning I wouldn't say this positions
winning but it's definitely Rubinstein
who's pressing and let's see how he
makes it work g4 g4 makes sense actually
he's trying to change off some pawns but
g4 is also very committal what's wrong
with g4 strategically
well as pawns can move backwards you
can't ever play g3 and take away a very
important square the f4 square and
another scare that's going to be very
important in this game the h3 h4 square
because the black King can potentially
go in that direction
and take and put pressure on the h-bomb
she plays King f6 of course and the two
threats and some pressure on the a pawn
black is still pressing and it's not
unlikely to win the game King f2 King g5
you're heading this direction
rookie 2 and rookie 2 is a good move
why well in general in end games you
want to have active rooks if you get the
chance to activate it do so so I think
rookie 2 is pretty good as if you would
be waiting around eventually you might
run out of useful moves so rookie to
Brooke did say 4 takes now we have to
decide what to play here there's another
critical moment
f-for if you go ahead for I might check
you don't worry h4 cuz I made
mmm-hmm King it for I might have recaps
X putting pressure on this font
do you think about it the king on f2 is
well-placed right it's not too far from
the Queen side but it's still defending
the King side pawns yes yes so exactly
so rookie to check is a very strong move
asking some questions now if white goes
up to e3 which I would prefer because
you want an active King even though it
like has its drawbacks because your
pawns will get beat so Marshall chose
actually to play King e1 and even though
I don't like it the engine likes it and
I don't like saying that but if the
objective truth is that that's the best
move that's the best move now in a
practical game though having your King
caught off on the first rank is very
dangerous and then in fact that's the
reason that Marshall is going to lose
this game so the first question here is
how to continue we achieved a lot
already we have an a pawn that's a
passed pawn we have a rook cutting off
the King but we need something something
extra to actually win the game
now the next moves won't be winning but
it will be a winning attempt from
Rubenstein
what's stopping so if you advance upon
I'm probably going to win the f5 pong
that check so usually when your rook is
in front of the pawn and I can get
behind you with route k-6
probably you're not winning the game
because you can you can't physically
promote it that's the issue there but if
you manage to support your pawn from the
sides possibly you can win especially as
this King is stuck on the first ring
so as I said white is threatening to win
upon right that rookie five and winning
that way so we want to avoid that
so if you go king f4 I can still win the
f5 fun but I attack it from f6 and take
the pawn we're trying to yeah we're
trying to win it yeah yeah yeah so we're
trying to hold on to this pawn and
that's our big hope here if you have
that extra pawn we can hope to win this
game in fact what's our plan after f4
what is black banking on yeah the black
king wants to go around go king h4 king
g3 and just gobble up the deck three
pawn if that happens we're in the safe
we're winning so rukiye seven eight six
now you still don't want to give away
all your pawns because the pawn is still
upon rook f7 a for now you're still
pushed upon but realistically you'll
only get the chance to win the game when
you get the chance to move your work
away so as long as your rook is in front
of the pawn probably you're not cleaning
yeah so in fact here
why it makes a big mistake the blaze
king the one exactly that would have
been the best play because as you push
the pawn you immediately go to a four
you defend this keep on on the sides and
then you walk all the way to be won and
you save the game but probably Marshall
didn't sense the danger placing the one
first
now it's gone a3 and the problem is you
can't really stop me from getting to g3
or if you do then I'll move my rook away
so check rook takes that for and now
rook f2 and the sad part is but yes you
can defend us so you don't lose
immediately the big threat here is just
Queens and if you take I check you and I
take the rook can still go king c1 but
this is already lost I'll turn black win
this
mm-hmm so King takes h3g 500k father's
plate first g5 but there's the screen
move and your King is just so far away
that you're losing so takes check takes
H takes and Rubenstein one because
you'll just sake and then Chasse in with
your pawn so so far the games that we
seen what Rubinstein utilized is the
fact that he made sure that all of his
opponent's pieces were restricted that
rook on a2 was really passive and the
king was caught off on the first rank
now why had the good defense should have
held but he was forced to defend Billy
well all right so let's look at the
third game that's great so probably this
is one of the most celebrated games the
Salva Rubenstein game and I think this
is celebrated because of the fact that
Rubenstein does the restriction of his
opponent's pieces to the max so first
off let's try to find out what white is
trying to achieve or trying to do in
this position even though it's black
smooth it's very important to note and
see what white is trying to achieve
so note that we have the bishop there
advantage and that's great and fun enjoy
but that does nothing for the moment and
it's it's kind of like a semi closed
position I'd say so potentially these
Knights have some good outposts so we
might want to take them away from white
yeah the f5 square looks really juicy
yes yes
so first yeah so Rubenstein will play g6
but first he makes sure that he gains
some space advantage on the Queen side
so he goes b5
yes so if g6 then possibly a four and
then this Bishop on C it would be rather
passive and it wouldn't have such a
bright future and if you have to
exchange off the bishop then you lose
the beloved bishop pair and then Fisher
and you'll know the camera would be sad
you wouldn't want that so a for wanted
to would be like the idea to play b5
first Bishop b3 g6 now and again this is
typical Rubinstein he's trying to
restrict the mobility of the opponent
pieces and then he looks for his own
plans nighty-night d1 which is probably
not the best move in fact if you if you
think about it in this position so he
plays 91 but instead of 91 probably
right should look for some action
especially because of all these back
pieces are kind of passive now we can't
really use it at the moment because it's
a closed position so there's no way to
get to them but if we would try how we
could try to open up the position for
white
mm-hmm it's an idea of getting the night
eventually although we still have to
tend for that e4 pawn so e4 is an idea
but probably c4 is it's a similar
concept the concept being if you go
let's say there should be seven I can
take take and now I will have some
counter play in the center and
potentially my knight could get more
active although you still will have to
defend that e4 pawn now that's kind of
the difference between 1908 and 2020
that today everyone is going to look for
plans themselves
and not just make moves at that moment
saw that wasn't looking for an idea
himself he was just making natural
natural developing moves now 91 is not a
bad move he's trying to get the knight
to d3 but that's not going to hinder
from Reuben sent to building up a good
position so King e7 King F 197 so the
knight is headed toward c5 when after
that how could we potentially gain an
advantage with black because already we
would have a beautiful pony on c5 but
that's usually not enough to win a game
so it's kind of logical that with all of
our pieces being on the queenside we're
looking for queenside plans right
yes yes so exactly a five as you said
that's what Rubinstein is going to aim
for he's trying to gain some space and
start from there
93 85 now if you would play a four now
that would actually help me as black
does I be happy to get an open platform
our rook mine a main issue is right now
as the district is kind of passive it
doesn't really do that much but white is
playing conservatively and plays a three
and if you wouldn't know how Rubinstein
plays you might not find the next move
but as we already know and established
Rubinstein will start playing for a
restriction probably white wants to play
c4 so revenge time make sure that will
never happen
ship a6
yeah yeah
yeah so both Bishop a6 and night b6 are
legitimate moves but probably as I would
imagine Rubinstein wanted to be sure
that it's safe if you could worship a6
probably there are some ghost threats
because you have to defend both the
night and upon the f7 I don't think it
works but Rubinstein was in no rush to
chance it so he played Knight b6 now he
puts pressure on the C 4 square and on
the a 4 square and again is black better
of course he's better but why it is
slowly running out of ideas
he plays King e2 and now it's time to go
forward how can we go forward here in
this position
also don't forget that Rubenstein is
still very conscious about the fact that
night c5 could come at any moment
yes exactly Bishop d6 you can see how he
slowly slowly pushes back the white
pieces now this night is very nice on d3
but it won't be nice there for long as
I'm going for c5 c4 and a be pushed back
nine f1 c5 and again why does a little
bit late to the party if then I would be
on e3 probably you could go Knight d5
and build a stronghold but sure one
Tempe late c5 Knight c1 c4 Bishop c2 and
again there's no question about it
we're better here but Rubinstein is in
no rush to play a move such as b4 which
would be a you know a choice of many
youngsters these days going for
immediate action but he says okay I'm
better there's no need to rush he plays
Bishop a6 so he's actually setting up
the threat of b4 and he might play it if
white stays on the a6 f1 diagonal but
it's still waiting and as the question
for solving are you going to stay there
or are you going to move with your king
solving moves the King okay I'll bring
my bishop back King e2 and in fact
tricky as it may seem Rubinstein won a
little bit of time with this he could
have played Bishop d7 immediately but it
would be by to move Bishop c5 again
activating these pieces
he could play b4 at any moment but what
he's saying is okay it's your problem
keep calculating the idea of b4 and I'm
gonna play it when it's just right 93 h5
again making sure that there are no
funny jumps attacking funny Knight d5
well that's an option yeah but 95 is
actually not that big of a danger and
it's not that dangerous here because I
can go f5 and then just corralled upon
that rook b8 and 95 yeah this is pretty
bad for whites so solvus stuck
she plays h4 King e6 slowly taking away
even this idea of 95 g3 rook f8 again
not giving away his plans he's saying
okay I might be playing f5 but in fact
you never can be sure you didn't play at
five yet he might actually just change
his plans and play b4 b4 should we react
should we take on b3 on pass on yep that
would just activate white so Rubinstein
just takes and drops back and in fact
that's that kind of the good way of
playing that that's why I like Brooke f8
well Ben Stein's move because if you
would have played any pawn moves you
would have been committed to the idea of
breaking through on the Kings side after
rook f8 b for rubenstein gets gets the
luxury of going the ship d6 and say okay
change of plans
you gave me an open file so I might as
well just go that direction
King e1 and change your plans I don't
have to play on the Kings side anymore I
just scared you now I'm going back 92
rokay 3 again restricting the knight has
nowhere to go it has to constantly
defend that pawn on c3 King D to Knight
a 4 again slowly but surely but is
getting tied down
rugby 1 okay - just tying the knot
Knight see 192 Bishop c7 so raise this
bishop headed
what is your first guess
yes obviously it goes to be six and
those to fianchetto bishops will do some
damage again also he's slowly improving
he's a no rush f3
there should be 691 f6 so f6 actually
has an idea in mind he is preparing the
concept of breaking with g5 and trying
to create a passport now is he going to
do it immediately
probably not but he's getting ready to
do so not be - now it takes me to black
really don't have a choice here because
takes B takes Knight c4 is a threat and
you wouldn't want that
so Knight takes B to rook takes B to R
ok one activating the rook trying to get
behind those pawns attack the weakness
is on f3 and probably later on g3 rugby
1 takes takes and suddenly after this
blow by Rubinstein the game will be
practically over its Rubinstein to move
and conquer at all
yep the next move is going to be a
restrictive move as well
so no note that this excuse me
note that this night is kind of stuck
and it has to defend and ten for these
fonts so we want to make sure that night
will never ever move again
did you play g5 I will try to run back
and hold the forts together so you
really don't want my king to participate
yes exactly the bishop f2 and it is big
trouble here because g5 is just a
monstrous move so Salva played g4 but if
you go Bishop c2 let's say I go g5 and
you can't do anything
you're just a spectator you're just
gonna watch me push the H pawn and
congratulate me on a wonderful game you
can't really do anything because this
Knight cannot really move and then your
king cannot come and defend against that
threat
so solve that tries to salvage with g4
but that's a pump nygean
but let's see how Rubinstein shows fine
technique here bishop f2 9 h3 obviously
this position by now is completely
winning but there's nothing that you can
mess up your ship g3 kingi - king f7 so
first off there's one danger in this
position well one of them is that if you
change this bishop for this night you
get an opposite colored bishop and game
and that is varied rorish also the
position is fairly closed right so we
have to keep that in mind that we need
to infiltrate by its position before
right to build up a fortress probably
it's not likely to happen here but you
never know so you place King f1 Bishop
c8 9 G 1 H 492 Bishop h3 check and in
fact this is very important
rubenstein doesn't push that pong all
the way up to h3 he gives an option to
push that pawn later we should be 1 and
again he goes on and restricts the
development of this night because after
Bishop e1 again this night is stuck and
that's not the only thing that's stuck
now after this maneuver of Bishop b7 c 8
to h3 you can't even play King age -
because Bishop f1 and I gobble the whole
army
so Bishop c2 King g6
it should be one white is basically just
watching and spectating King g5 gypsy -
Bishop d7 and this is actually one of
devices and the reasons my rubenstein
plays the endgame so well
he's extremely patient he already
achieved a lot and white was put in a
neared suit swamp but he says okay I
can't really go forward this way so I
might as well retreat a little bit go to
Bishop d7 and come up with a different
plan
kingi - Bishop d2 the King still needs
to be near this pawn because at any
moment I can start running it should be
1 h3 now in g3 check engage 4 so the
plan was to bring the king up and now
we'll be able to go behind and put
pressure on the f3 pawn bishop c2 bishop
e8 nygean but that's already hopeless
king h1 could even take on c3 of course
check Bishop h5 and white resigned
because if you go Bishop do you want I
can go Bishop you want and your and I
cannot move anymore because I'll take
here and there's also a beautiful
checkmate here
and what is this if not total domination
so in fact solver resigned earlier but
this is a good way to end this lecture
so that that's why I kind of like
Rubenstein's games because he first
restricts his opponents play and then
goes into the kill and that's how you do
it
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you